a pesar de que el confinamiento ya entró
en vigor en francia esto no impidió que
las personas llegaran hasta aquí a las
puertas de la basílica de nuestra señora
de la asunción' para continuar esta
vigilia venir a traer a flores encender
velas tener unos momentos de oración
hablar hablamos con varias de las
personas que vinieron aquí una feligresa
que tenía digamos emociones encontradas
después de saber lo que ocurrió en el
jueves en la mañana y también con unas
monjas que decidieron pasar también un
momento aquí no tengo miedo se lo digo
claramente todo el mundo tiene miedo
como cristiana tengo miedo porque cuando
camino por la calle no sé uno no sabe
que viene detrás de uno
sentí rabia al comienzo pero no por
mucho tiempo ellos no tendrán ni mi odio
ni nos dividirán y eso no va a hacerme
cambiar de parecer no hubo ni voy a
hacer amalgama entre los musulmanes y
quienes cometieron estos actos estoy
contra eso debemos permanecer juntos
entre emociones encontradas entre
opiniones
divergentes se anunció que ahora ni se
tendrá 120 policías más que vendrán a
reforzar la seguridad pero sobre todo
hay una pregunta que se hacen todos aquí
en la población y es porque en niza una
vez más fue blanco de un atentado
terrorista el tercero en los últimos
cinco años